come on you're legit messing up my
freakin karaoke wait to do a table read
for that this little show that I'm
working on and super excited about it
but after that is what is gonna get
really really wild some of you may have
seen on my snapchat story today we've
got a really big task ahead of us need
to replace all of these lightbulbs and
turn them into these I've been having a
little bit of a dilemma I got a bunch of
hue lights and I'm working on a super
fun video for hue but the problem is I
don't have a ladder and I tried to be
super crafty and today I might die and I
just wanted to be the first person to
tell you do not do that it's very
dangerous some people suggested that I
find somebody to do it for me that I
have to find someone new so yeah this is
a good stop this is a good so this is a
great song
freaking radio ahead
my
like some good headset up here in the
copper
why is why are things never easy
I don't remember my seat down they
usually have let loose or something -
that's alright if I need to I'll figure
it out a car oh thank you I wanna
release handle and push the backrest
into the desired position make sure the
backrest is locked properly palms down
on the seat okay but like how big can a
ladder really be how am I gonna get you
in my car that's the question you're not
gonna fit in my car you're not gonna fit
my car it's like no I don't need a man
but like
I am so incredibly grateful for nice
people
no let's just what we came for
I see the lies we know is Rover
I guess it's no surprise
over
Oh